thank you
defends Butler a bump the grind the
gyration and the two in the foul and
they're having words
and he's cut or no
after that three by Grant Williams he
was having words with Jimmy Butler on
the way down
here's the dish by Brown and here's the
shot make by Williams and look at the
words
already Williams and Jimmy Butler is
smiling about it and then here's the
contact at the ensuing play
and let's go head to head guys
thank you I agree thank you Butler we'll
take it into the defense of Brett
Williams shot clock at four here he
accelerates and finds two oh and gave
him the two small sign
to Grant Williams be careful when you
poke the bear now Jimmy Butler is going
to have his hands on the ball all the
time right yeah just put his head down
against Grant Williams and got all the
way to the cup
[Music]
well go up one with the three
Butler drives Andrea Williams in a
15-footer will tie it at 100.
out of Iowa stream Williams the
defensive assignment
inside for the lead that's what he wants
Grant Williams on him the Celtics are
going to have to come and double
absolutely going at Grant Williams
once again the butler did it from Miami
Butler in Brogden shot clock at three
toddler will chisel
oh my goodness
great offensive rebound by bam out of
Bio inside everybody for the dump and a
five little monkey
thank you
it's Gabe Vincent
setting up two-point shotgun
not Jimmy Butler not bam out of Bio but
Gabe Vincent are you kidding me
everyone who wants to talk about the
depth of the Boston Celtics here's one
of these undrafted players again with a
dagger